welcome to hell the sign says
at the entrance to the capitol on the
outskirts of the city they're hunkering
down and preparing to fight with all
their might
but they're taking every precaution and
they've asked us to keep the location
here secret and protect their identities
what do you have to do do you think
you should
just
should should shoot
and protect
my home
it's all it's easy
all around the city they are building
defenses
they've seen the pummeling of other
cities and with a 40-mile convoy of
russian military hardware sitting on the
edge of the capital they believe they're
next
there are several warnings of mines
ahead
the streets are scattered with scrap
metal spikes and tires
and huge metal anti-tank hedgehogs
anything to slow the advance of the
russian troops
there's frenetic activity inside the
dozens of civil defence stations where
every room is piled high with donations
as the water supplies food
water food sleeping mats
soldiers and civilians are working in
unison these are the ones who've opted
to stay behind whatever happens
these people ran businesses had careers
just over a week ago their lives now put
on hold and almost certainly changed
forever
but with time running out we were told
over and over again how much they needed
tougher international action nobody
knows what
putin can do
today or even tomorrow and we need
actions right now not next week or next
month it
it will not work so we need actions
yesterday
this is what they're preparing to take
on russian military hardware and
soldiers all edging ever closer to the
capital these pictures were released by
the russian defense ministry purporting
to show their troops entering the kiev
region
the videos come after u.s defense
officials claimed without providing any
evidence that they believed the convoy
had stalled and was having logistical
issues
the capital civilians believe it's only
a matter of time but insist they're
ready
i can't explain you what the feelings of
our ukrainians in here is because
everyone has relatives have the related
loved ones who are fire right now
who was wounded right now who was killed
right now it's it's it's impossible to
explain to people who don't live in such
such of despair but this despair it's
not despair oh we are surrendered no
it's despair we will win we will go
we will we will fight you back to hell
where your places
many of these people hadn't picked up a
weapon over a week ago and now barely
flinch at the sounds of war and then
days ago i was a teacher about the
makeup and
i had i worked with students and showed
them how to make the makeup and
everything was very peaceful does that
worry you hearing sounds like that are
you
scared normal for me already
it's normal life your life has changed
so much it's just like no fear i'm like
i don't feel anything inside already
her friend is a graduate in biochemistry
and is still studying her masters
no purpose for this so why do they do
this i want to fight also because this
is my country this is my home
my thoughts my family
all of my
i know pressures no
everything is here and i i would like to
to be this like that way it was before
[Music]
taking ukraine's capital remains the
russian prize and the people here know
that
alex crawford sky news kiev